- Der Gast steht hier immer
im Mittelpunkt. Und das ist halt wichtig,
dass die Leute zu dem Gast einfach
offen und freundlich sind.
- Es kommt natürlich auch sehr,
sehr viel Fachwissen noch dazu:
Über das Essen muss man
Bescheid wissen, das heißt,
wenn die Teller am Pass stehen in der
Küche, muss man direkt sehen, was es ist.
Also man muss
verschiedene Fleischsorten kennen,
verschiedene Gemüsesorten kennen,
man muss sich mit Wein auskennen,
man muss nachher wissen,
welcher Wein passt zu welchem Essen,
weil das gehört auch dazu,
dass man die Gäste berät.
Also es kommt auch noch sehr,
sehr viel an Fachkenntnis [hinzu],
gerade im Bereich Essen und Trinken.
- Aber auch wichtig ist
die Kommunikation im Team.
So was muss jemand, der hier arbeitet,
natürlich auch können.
- Wenn man noch gar keine Erfahrung hat,
kann man gucken, ob irgendwo
ein Aushilfsjob meinetwegen angeboten wird,
wo man dann angelernt wird.
Da wird man angelernt für das,
was in dem Restaurant gebraucht wird.
Und wenn man sich dann dazu
entscheidet, eine Ausbildung zu machen,
ja dann geht’s halt los.
Dann ist noch die Berufsschule mit dabei,
um die ganzen
theoretischen Sachen zu lernen,
und die Praxis lernt man dann im Betrieb.
- Wichtig ist halt, dass man den Betrieb
findet, der zu einem passt,
und dass man dann
auch in den Betrieb passt
und zu den Kollegen und ins Team.
- Der einzige Nachteil ist die Arbeitszeit,
dass man halt viel am Wochenende arbeiten
muss und auch viel abends arbeiten muss.
Also wenn Geburtstagsfeiern sind,
dass man auch mal keine Zeit hat,
um da hinzugehen.
Die Vorteile sind,
dass wirklich jeder Tag anders ist,
dass man sehr viel
Abwechslung hat in dem Beruf.
Also man macht zwar
jeden Tag das Gleiche,
aber dadurch, dass jeden Tag
andere Gäste da sind –
manchmal hat man einen Zehnertisch,
manchmal hat man einen Geburtstag,
manchmal eine Hochzeit, also
jeder Tag läuft wirklich komplett anders,
und das macht halt super Spaß.
Die Gäste sind normalerweise echt nett.
Und was auch richtig viel Spaß macht, ist,
wenn die Gäste mit
schlechter Laune kommen
und mit guter Laune wieder gehen.